as well good evening if I were an
actress I would be passionate sensitive
courageous sexy complex free strong
funny intense and graceful hey if I were
an actress I'd be an even better actor
here are the nominees for actress in
linen roll
Jessica Chastain zero dark circle
Jennifer Lawrence silver linings
playbook
while in general what beasts of the
southern wild normalize the impossible
and the Oscar goes to Jennifer Lawrence
first Academy
Bart
thank you
you guys are just standing up cuz you
feel bad that I fell and that's really
embarrassing but thank you
this is nuts um thank you to the Academy
and thank you to the women this year you
were so magnificent and so inspiring and
not just those of you in my category and
it's been so amazing getting to know you
and you've been so nice and you've made
this experience unforgettable and thank
you to the best producing team and Bruce
Khanna John and my team at CAA and ID PR
and Bradley and our entire cast Chris
Jackie
Bob and our crew uh and my family
happy birthday Emmanuel um thank you so
much this